all right blade Smith welcome to the
forge let's get into it
as I'm sure you've already guessed you
guys will be salvaging your medals from
this here burned out SUV you guys will
only have three hours and that time
starts now I'm Bo giesen 52. I love the
forge it's just molding metal to
whatever you want it to be the artistic
side of it you can just do anything when
you can move metal I crawl down there
and there's some big round bar stock I'm
going to heat this up and I'm going to
try out that press
my plan for the round is to get this
thing drawn out I can finally start my
heat treat both getting ready to quench
leave her down in there
I grab a file I ran it across the blade
not hardened
this time I'm going to bring it out a
little hotter
there we go nice color nice color you
want to see
I pull it out of the quench I hit it
with the file
okay it's good to go thank God I'm
finally done with that and I can get on
the grinder and remove some of this
material
go back to grinding I guess
I'm at the grinder I'm trying to clean
this thing up and then I realize this is
just a rectangle of nothing
I'm going to put a bend in the entire
blade to give it a little more character
and then I'm also going to grind the tip
I'm going to have to heat treat for a
third time which is a big risk
I could have a catastrophic failure
especially after my last quench but you
know this is a competition and I've got
to make some kind of details because
it's just too boring let's do it posed
in for his third point
I pull it out I get the file it skates
right across it we're good I'm ready to
move on back to the grinder
my name is Kevin Adams I am a technical
instructor for the United States Army
and I'm a part-time bladesmith my
grandfather and my father worked in the
same steel mill together so their
influence enabled me to be able to pick
up the trade fairly quickly my son used
to race Motocross and I was his mechanic
that entire time so I know where there's
good steel I got my steel and the forge
everything's looking good
I have to grind in good profile and get
my handle ground in and get the bolster
set for the blade
I'm looking at my piece inside the forge
I'm getting ready to quench it that
looks like a melted stick of butter look
at that thing
put her in the quench I pull my blade
out I see good color the blade it does
have a little bit of twist to it but I
know I can get that out by hand my name
is Eric Fontaine and I have been
bladesmithing now for almost 10 years I
stay with it because it's a comfort
place for me and just being able to
create something it's a really cool
experience so I'm immediately looking
for Springs because I know those are
going to be 51.60 so now I need to get
the coil spring straight
you got it nice and hot before he went
to straighten it out that was smart my
next order of business is to go over to
the big blue to widen it and flatten it
and I put it in at a diagonal so not
only does it flatten it but it also
widens it at the same time I'm finishing
up at the grinder and I'm ready for
quenching
the blade is screaming hot at the tip
[Music]
that's way too hot I think it came out
quite well
I'm checking my blade and I have a
slight warp near the tank I put my
blades in the Vise just to try to
straighten it out just a little bit it's
working
almost
if I go too much on the Vise the blade
would snap so I decide that I'm not
going to press my luck any further and
I'm going to grind the rest of it out
five four three two one turn off your
machines put down your tools round one
is officially over
gentlemen congratulations the three of
you are moving forward into round two of
our competition if you guys look over to
your right you see we've got a pile of
burnt out wood we found in the SUV that
is all you have for your handle material
anybody used burnt wood before no not
yet well there's a first time for
everything all right guys as always
watch the clock you will only have two
hours in round two of the competition
and that time starts now all right we
got here so all this wood looks the same
to me
sounds solid so I'm just gonna run with
it seems good the way this handle fits
in the judge's hands is so important
they've got a lot of power coming down
on these chops so what I'm doing now is
putting these deep contoureds in the
handle for the judge's hands I think I
put a nice handle on this piece I hope I
got it sharp enough for the test but I
feel good I need my tank fixed before I
can even put my handle on
I've got to keep the blade cool so it
doesn't lose my heat tree so like
wrapping in some wet towels heat up the
Tang from the bolster back just so I can
straighten it so Kevin's back there
putting some serious torque on that Tang
trying to straighten it out I got my
Tang straight there's a little bit of
grinding I can do to get some of the
little imperfections out I'm happy with
it
great
I pride myself on putting a good handle
on the piece that I make because the
handle on a blade is the interface so
it's like a keyboard on a computer I'm
going to flare out the ends so your hand
stays in a good gripping position
I don't think there's anybody else that
burns their wood before they put it on
the handle that's only something you'll
find on forged in the fire I'm trying to
get the pins to go through I'm trying to
get everything lined up
close but it's just quite not there
I don't want to force it so I'm
constantly going back to the drill press
check it again
that's better
I don't know what I did differently but
I get it to go together and we're in
business my next step is to go over to
the grinder
until I get a shape that feels
comfortable I'm gonna make this blade
awesome I found some clear nail polish I
paint on the blade forged in Fire and I
go into the acid for a few minutes
powering your ass
acid is one awesome looking knife
five three
tools turn off your machines round two
is over
welcome to the strength test our
tailgate chop
now I'm going to take each of your
knives and repeatedly and mercilessly
beat them into this SUV liftgate what
your blades do is liftgate I'm not too
concerned about I want to see what the
gate does to your blades Bo you're up
first how you feeling get some Jay
foreign
[Music]
you do have some spots a little bit of
rolling there's a couple spots like
right down here where it's really not an
edge the handle is still secure it's
just right in here this spot even though
you've got it contoured this kind of
digs in but didn't fly apart good job
thank you Jay Kevin how you feeling
nervous
good job
good job Kevin thank you you got I mean
the slightest I mean you know it's
barely catch a nail a little bit of
rolling it's still straight as it was
the only problem I have is
when you're doing an integral this tends
to become part of your handle as opposed
to a guard so there's a lot of handle
left over but nothing moved you survived
the tailgate chop good job thank you and
then there was error and there was Eric
ready to go give a hell
foreign
you survived good job we do have a few
issues though and you can see you got
chipping and rolling from there to there
that being said it held up extremely
well the handle I like the contouring
you did but the problem is still pretty
round I could pretty easily spin this in
my hand but that being said still in one
piece good job thank you
the sharpness test the fuel hose slice
now to find out how sharp your weapons
are I will take your weapons and try to
cut through these fuel Hills now unlike
the strength disc this is all about what
your Edge will do to these hose oh
you're first you ready for this I'm
ready
all right both first stop your handle
construction it fits my hand nicely now
your Edge it's not very sharp all the
way through the fuel hose it cut it but
it didn't cut all the way through but
overall we know
you'll cut thank you all right Kevin
your turns are you ready oh yes let's do
this
all right Kevin let's talk about your
weapon here first up I like the handle
construction I really appreciate the
integral part that you put into your
handle here it's got a nice feel to it I
love that you curved it because the
heavier front leg is it's nice to be
able to have that control
now your edge here looks like the
strength has really dulled your blade
also it cut the first hose but not all
the way through but overall sir we know
it cuts all right thank you all right
Eric your turn so you ready I'm ready
let's do this
all right Eric now your handle
construction is very smooth I like the
flare that you have I can see where it
can rotate a little bit now your Edge
during the strength test it took some
dulling but because it is so thin it
actually works for this particular test
overall sir your weapon it will come
thank you
we gave you guys a hard Challenge and
you all performed really well in our
test the judges have deliberated and
only two of you can go forward into
round three of the competition
and the blade Smith leaving the forge is
Bo unfortunately not going forward in
the next round of the competition and
Jay's going to tell you why Bo you guys
perform pretty equally in a strength
test and then the front end of that
handle being uncomfortable to hold on to
for very long the reasons we're letting
you go okay
but we want to thank you for all your
hard work and especially your great
sportsmanship in round one but
unfortunately I'm gonna have to ask you
to please step off the fourth floor okay
I'm disappointed
even though it didn't go my way I'm
really proud of the work that I did here
and I'm going to keep on making knives